bienvenido a la presentación de
problemas avanzados de razones vamos a
empezar con el siguiente problema
imagínate que tenemos un salón de clases
donde el total de estudiantes aquí le
voy a poner el total es 57 y donde la
razón de niñas a niños lo voy a escribir
así a / b es igual a 4 sobre 15 a 4
sobre 15 hasta ahorita todo se ve muy
normal pero lo interesante es la
siguiente pregunta cuántos niños
necesitan salir para que la nueva razón
de niñas a niños sea ahora 4 entre 11
déjame escribir la pregunta por acá
cuántos niños
cuando los niños
niños necesitan salir necesitan
salir
al ir
para que a / b
que la razón de niñas a niños a / b sea
igual a 4 sobre 11 muy bien esta es la
pregunta que queremos responder y se ve
fascinante un primer paso que podemos
hacer es encontrar el número de niños y
de niñas que hay en el salón y ya
sabemos hacer eso porque hicimos un
problema muy similar en el vídeo
anterior entonces déjame reescribir esta
información como sigue si el total de 57
y a es la cantidad de niñas y ves la
cantidad de niños entonces además ve a
más b es igual a 57 y si multiplicamos
por b esta igualdad nos queda que a
es igual a 4 sobre 15 x b de modo que
podemos sustituir el valor de aquí
arriba y obtener una ecuación en b vamos
a hacer eso nos quedaría que 4 sobre 15
x b más b es igual déjame hacer eso
igual más bonito es igual a 57 b es 15
sobre 15 entonces esta suma es 19 sobre
15 nos queda que 19 sobre 15 b es igual
a 57 multiplicando por 15 y dividiendo
entre 19 que da que b es igual a 57 x 15
y dividido entre 19 y observa que de 57
entre 19 es 3
estoy aquí es 3 de modo que b es igual a
3 por 15 o sea 45 muy bien esto nos da
el número de niños de niños del salón y
sabemos que en total son 57 estudiantes
de modo que la cantidad de niñas es lo
que falta para 57 es decir a es igual a
12 muy bien esto nos da la cantidad de
niñas y de niños en el salón y otra
forma de escribir que la razón a / b es
4 entre 15 es poner a / b a / b como 12
entre 45 esto es igual a 12 entre 45
ahora en el problema se van a salir
algunos niños y nosotros queremos que la
nueva razón sea ahora 4 entre 11 y 4
entre 11 entonces cómo le hacemos para
plantear eso algebraica mente aquí
tenemos a / b pero nosotros no nos
interesa a / b si no nos interesa que se
salgan algunos niños déjame ponerle a
esa cantidad a la cantidad de niños que
se salen x vamos a pensar que salen
salem x vale entonces cuál sería la
nueva razón cuál sería el nuevo valor
este de la razón de niñas entre niños
bueno pues la cantidad de niñas seguiría
siendo ah pero tenemos que dividir entre
la nueva cantidad de niños entre b b - x
si se salieron x y sabemos que a es el
12 y b es 45 entonces la nueva razón
sería 12 dividido entre 45 - x va si
esto te confunde un poquito velo y
medita lo con calma simplemente estamos
diciendo que la cantidad de niñas se
quedó igual y que la cantidad de niños
disminuyó en x vale entonces esto sería
la nueva razón y la información que aquí
nos dicen es que queremos que la nueva
razón sea igual
a 4 dividido entre 11 y con esto ya
podemos plantear una ecuación en x bueno
es muy importante que veas de dónde
salió esta expresión sale bueno vamos a
resolver ahora esta está esta igualdad o
bien vamos a despejar x multiplicando
por 11 11 por 12 132 nos queda que 132
es igual a 4 por 45 45 más 45 es 90 90
90 180 4 por menos x es menos 4x
de esta forma menos 4x a ver voy a tener
que resolverlo aquí es igual a 132 menos
180 es menos 48 menos 48 dividiendo
entre menos 4 nos queda que x es igual
es igual a 12 y esto lo que nos dice es
que se tienen que salir 12 niños para
que la razón sea 4 entre 11 y podemos
verificarlo
vamos a ver si esto tiene sentido si se
salen 12 niños entonces ahora la razón
sería sería la cantidad de niñas es
igual sería 12 y tenemos que dividir
entre 45 menos 12 45 - 26 33 y en efecto
simplificando un 3 nos queda cuatro 4
dividido entre 11 de modo que la
respuesta es que se tienen que salir 12
niños muy bien entonces parece un poco
difícil y aquí hay un poco de fracciones
pero en realidad no es tan difícil
verdad simplemente hay que plantear una
ecuación y meterle un poquito de álgebra
bueno vamos a hacer otro problema déjame
bajar para tener un poco más de espacio
vamos a cambiar de color para que no sea
tan monótono voy a hacerlo en
saleh supongamos que tenemos una canasta
de frutas y sabemos que en esa canasta
de frutas hay manzanas y plátanos y la
razón de manzanas entre plátanos es
igual a 5 entre 10 y 9 5 entre 19 y
luego vamos a agregar 23 plátanos déjame
poner una flechita y vamos a poner que
vamos a poner que vamos a agregar ya
vamos a poner que vamos a poner eso
suena divertido 23 plátanos plátanos
vale y sabemos que después de hacer esto
la nueva proporción de manzanas a
plátanos nos queda 10 entre 61 como
escribiríamos eso bueno pues la cantidad
de manzanas permanece igual y ahora la
cantidad de plátanos son 23 más
entonces manzanas entre plátanos más 23
la nueva razón de manzanas a plátanos es
igual a 10 entre 60 y 110 entre 61 bueno
esta es la información que nos dan y la
pregunta es la siguiente
la pregunta es cuál es la cantidad de
fruta en la canasta le voy a poner así
cantidad
de fruta de fruta
en la canasta en la canasta
después de meter los plátanos los
plátanos adicionales después
de meter de meter
los plátanos los plátanos la
los adicionales
sí o males adicionales
muy bien esto de aquí es la pregunta si
te das cuenta pues cuando plantea el
problema ya de una sugerencia porque ya
escribí las dos ecuaciones que
necesitamos en la primera nos dicen que
la razón inicial de manzanas a plátanos
es 5 entre 19 y después al agregar 23
plátanos nos dicen que es 10 entre 61
pero aquí ya lo escribimos simplemente
tenemos la misma cantidad de manzanas
pero ahora los plátanos aumentan en 23
bueno esto nos da dos ecuaciones tenemos
dos variables así que podemos resolver
este sistema déjame despejar en ambos el
valor de m despejando en la primera nos
queda que m m es igual a 5 entre 19 x p
y despejando m en la segunda nos queda
que m es igual
10 p 23 o sea sería 10
+ 230 dividido entre 61 entre 61 esto lo
podemos escribir como 10 p entre 61 más
230 entre 61 y aquí tenemos dos
expresiones para m por lo tanto son
iguales así que podemos igualar las
podemos poner que 50 y 19 lo voy a poner
de este lado 5 entre 19 x p es igual
esta expresión de acá 10 entre 61 x p
más 230 230 entre 61 y aquí podríamos
resolver este esta ecuación lineal pero
hay muchas fracciones y ya no me queda
tanto tiempo así que así que pues
simplemente voy a poner cuál es el valor
que nos debe quedar nos queda que p es
igual a 38 y tú lo puedes verificar con
calma en tu cuaderno bueno si tenemos
que la cantidad de plátanos es 38 y nos
están diciendo este que m entre p s 50 y
19 entonces m de hecho lo podemos ver
aquí la cantidad de manzanas es igual a
5 entre 19 x 38 que es igual a 10 muy
bien entonces al inicio tenemos 10
manzanas y tenemos 38 plátanos entonces
en total tenemos 48 piezas de fruta
entonces tenemos 10
38 que son 48 pero luego agregamos 23
plátanos más 23 entonces sería 48 23 que
es 71 y de esta forma al final tenemos
71 piezas de fruta en la canasta vamos a
hacer un breve repaso nos dicen la razón
inicial de manzanas a plátanos luego
agregamos 23 plátanos las manzanas se
quedan igual y abajo nos queda plátanos
más 23 y nos dicen que esto es 10 entre
61 a partir de ahí podemos despejar el
valor de m
en ambas igualdades obteniendo esta
expresión y esta expresión luego los
igualamos con eso podemos encontrar el
valor de p y teniendo el valor de pe ya
es fácil encontrar el valor de m los
sumamos y recordamos que se agregaron
otros 23 plátanos muy bien entonces la
respuesta es 71 y me parece que con
estos ejemplos ya estás listo para
resolver por tu cuenta algunos problemas
avanzados